because i asked the word believe
and as a scientist which the students
are they're training to be scientists
your job you deal in knowledge
probabilities likelihoods so my
self-definition of knowledge is to
confirm something to be true
and my own personal definition of belief
is to accept to accept something that's
true without knowing that it's true
and as scientists we just don't do that
this conversation with
an impressive human being i once heard
the best life advice is to live to
impress yourself
uh keema lachey he impresses me as a
peaceful warrior as a man of science as
a phd as a reformed uh kid from uh from
tough circumstances who who came off and
and does such great work as a as an
educator and now the incoming
president-elect of the national society
of black physicist my friend hakeem
al-shay enjoy
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
and we are here today with uh a true
inspiration
a man i have wanted on this podcast uh
for years and doubled down on last year
during the pandemic uh my audience was
so intent and intense about getting on
today's guess who's hakeem oluseg who is
let me read this quick biography this
could take up most of the hour he's an
american astrophysicist cosmologist
inventor educator science communicator
author actor veteran humanitarian he's
named a visiting robinson professor at
george mason university uh i reckon
which recognizes outstanding faculty in
2021 he published an autobiography that
we're going to be talking about a
quantum life my unlikely journey from
the street to the stars his best known
scientific contributions are on the
transfer of mass and energy in the sun's
atmosphere the development of spaceborne
observatories playing a role in jwst
we're going to talk about that
transformative technologies he's got at
least three patents that i read and
we're gonna go over those ion propulsion
computer chips optics
okay my first question why are you doing
this interview do you have any time left
in your freaking calendar to do an
interview with someone so pointless as
me oh man are you kidding me pointless
not at all i i absolutely have a lot of
time for this um dude listen i hack the
system sir that's why i have time
you don't do what everybody tells you so
when i was at berkeley as a postdoc
there was a same story about the
berkeley postdocs and uh what happened
allegedly was that there was this
european uh postdoctonous american post
doctor walking down the street and some
guy comes up and pulls a gun he says
give me your wallet
and the american guy hands over his
wallet immediately and the european guy
goes no you can't have my wallet and the
guy was like what you gonna give me your
wallet he's like no you better run and
the guy runs and so the european guy
turns to the american guy and says look
man you can't give your wallet to every
guy who shows up with a gun
you'll be broke
i got that uh impression once from jim
simons who's the patron of our simon's
observatory simon zaray
mathematician code breaker
philanthropist and once i was hosting a
charity fundraiser for his philanthropy
called math for america which is a great
charity um and uh and then there was
this famous scientist who happens to be
here in san diego and he was hitting him
up for money for his own charity so this
guy's hitting up jim simons for a
charity of his own at jim simon's own
charity fundraiser that i was headlining
and uh and then afterwards jim looks at
me and he goes if i gave away a dollar
to every person who told me i was if
they were a genius i'd be broke the
guy's worth like 10 billion dollars so
yeah and you you can't yeah you got you
got to be vigilant you got to be
vigilant all right hakeem i told you
before we started uh that we were going
to begin with the question that you're
never supposed to answer you're never
supposed to ask
[Music]
which is uh which are the thing you're
never supposed to do which is to sit in
judgment of a book by its cover
i love to ask you got behind you i
listen to it on audio on audiobook here
i got the opening here we go here i
loved it it was narrated by
today's guest hakeem and uh team where
did you get the title a quantum life my
journey from the streets to the stars
what does that mean and what is that who
is that young man on the front is that
you
it is meant to represent me because i
meant to represent you know a
cross-section of humanity right a story
right my story is a story of humans that
occurs um a quantum life so man i went
through so many titles uh the the
quantum here has to do with a couple of
ideas right one of them is the idea of
initial conditions
determining uh the full trajectory in
classical physics but only determining
the probabilities of outcomes in quantum
physics so when we're all born we have
um you know certain probabilities of
where we're going to end up and you know
what you know i think of it almost like
an eigenvalue problem right like like
the the um time independent schrodinger
equation each human can be represented
as a vector in this multi-dimensional
space right that has to do with identity
so you know are you rich or poor are you
you know within there you know race
ethnicity sex gender you know all these
things right and then the situation that
we put you in in quantum mechanics we
call that the hamiltonian right what's
your left you know um
you know that matrix is life a society
right that you're placed in so um you
know you can calculate the probabilities
of certain outcomes right we don't
actually do that but you know if you
look at certain life outcomes they quite
often will um be a strong
function of zip code
yeah
right yeah
and initial conditions right so um
and you know so that was that's what i
was representing there and so
and and so my case is so extreme
that i i compare it to quantum tunneling
as well right you know breaking through
this barrier that just shouldn't be that
shouldn't be broken through and so my
unlikely journey from the street to the
stars
is basically about my journey from
living my you know my first four years
were like you know
good for
two-parent household you know older
sister community that generations of my
family had grown up in in east new
orleans
great then my parents divorced
and uh the next decade for me was uh
pretty bad to say the least but at the
same time
um you know certain passions were uh
engendered in me and so what makes my
story so unlikely
is what i was drawing it to and what i
was drawn into but um you know despite
that
i was able to still
uh achieve what i've achieved and so the
thing about it for me is
you know
i'm not the only person who's done the
things that i've done yeah right and how
that impacts a person's life and a
person's psyche again will depend on
their zip code so where i'm from people
will say oh you know that thing isn't
for me oh now i'm disqualified cause
i've done done these things right but
you know i've gotten to know you guys
all you i got to know the ceos the heads
of state you know all over the world the
government millionaires and i can't tell
you how many times i tell a little bit
about my story and then one of you
squeaky looking cats pulled me to cycle
let me tell you about me
i've never told anyone this you know
yeah so yeah it's pretty provocative
because you know when i think about that
uh i naturally because i'm a physicist i
have that bias i thought of like a path
integral i thought of a feynman path
integral or you know like the path was
unlikely right and path has a as it has
a has a kind of attention to us right
it's like that you seek out you know
kind of the the path that maximizes or
minimizes the action and there's a lot
of action in this book and we're going
to talk about the book the book has tons
of action both in the physics sense
etc but i want to take a big step back
and i want to i want my audience to
learn about your fascination with the
sun and starting off with the sun the
sun as a star and then we'll get into
new stars uh
old stars rather when it comes to jet
abs t but i want to talk about um first
of all most of my audience
is familiar with with theorists because
i have a lot of theorists a lot of nobel
prize winners come on they're they're
theorists not so many experimentalists
hardware builders rocket scientists
literally like yourself yeah so tell me
first of all what is there to know about
the sun the sun is the closest star you
know when my kids say what's the closest
star to the earth i say proxima centauri
no dad it's the it's the sun
right
yeah don't we know everything about the
sun
what's left to learn about i don't know
everything about the sun um
well because there are several reasons
uh
you know you can't literally you know
stick probes inside of it i mean you
gotta you have to observe the surface
and because humans are so dope they
figure out all these amazing ways to do
things like helioseismology where you
can figure out what's happening in
inside the core and even on the opposite
side of the sun um but the sun is not
like looking at other um
objects
because it's so close we get so much
detail that we can't see in other stars
right so when you see something from a
distance
you can think you understand it but then
when you look at it up close you're like
whoa there's a lot going on here that i
don't quite understand
and so the sun
also has utility as a tool
and that is is that it is our
plasma physics laboratory that has
magnetic field strengths and sizes and
you know energy content that's hard to
reproduce here on earth right if if
possible at all and so we
learn the plasma physics and you know if
you think about how much what percentage
of the baryonic matter in the universe
is in the form of plasmas
most of it
the short answer right so um
the uh the idea here is that you know
quite often we'll learn these plasma
physics processes on the sun and then
apply them elsewhere and that's sort of
what i've done in my career you know so
when i i often call my research hacking
the stars because you know stars you
know the sun is the only star that i've
studied to understand the actual object
and how it works but i've used the sun
and my and my knowledge from
studying the sun
to develop new technologies or to help
them to understand the universe like for
example you know supernova cosmology or
you know galactic archaeology you know
i'm not studying these pulsating stars
understanding the stars i'm using them
for another purpose right yeah
so when you looked at uh the sun using
the mista and i think that's how yeah
yeah yeah so that was your thesis
project
um
at stanford university where we
overlapped briefly i was there as a
postdoc in 99 you were uh here as a
student
well i actually finished in 99. oh yeah
yeah i remained strategically uh
registered for a year while i worked in
silicon valley
because i asked my phd about will you
pay me uh my tuition for another year
because i can't afford to move off
campus i know and at that time people
forget that was this that was the
first.com boom i lived like on literally
on the train tracks pretty much on alma
street yeah i almost got nailed by the
train a couple times uh but uh but tell
me about that rocket tell me about the
thrill of going to white sands with this
object that you spent so much of your
blood sweat and tears on along with your
dear beloved mentor art uh welcome to
talk about art because he was a towering
figure i remember his presence uh around
there but tell me about what it's like
to put your baby on a rocket and launch
your dreams to the stars with about i
think it's about a five to ten percent
chance that they'll either be
catastrophically destroyed or will
produce no data
i think it had to be at least 50 50 man
but
before we go further yeah i want to
establish
some sort of pat you know of a framing
because when people ask me questions
about like can you tell me what
fascinates you about the sun
it it it sets a framing and it has
assumptions in it that are not true and
those assumptions are is that young
hakeem thought oh what would i like to
be what would i like to study and then i
pursued that that's not how it worked
for me right for me it was
oh man high school is coming to an end
how do i live indoors and eat after this
oh i joined the military i'm out of the
military oh no what do i do oh i gotta
find a job can't find a job go to
college all right i'm in college learn
about this thing oh what do i do after
college here come these graduate
students saying yo we got this
conference you can come to and we'll
tell you about this thing called
graduate school then i get to stanford
and i'm like i don't trust none of y'all
but i trust him aren't walker
right so i didn't choose the sun i chose
our walker and that's so critical i
can't permit my interruption but but i
always tell my students it's not
important what you go because they're
all like should i put on that i want to
be an experimentalist because that gives
me a higher chance of getting into grad
school or i'm like i don't care what you
put on uh the most important
relationship you're going to have is
with your advisor that man or woman may
come to your come to your uh come to
your wedding you may go to the funeral
and et cetera et cetera you're gonna
have a bond with that person maybe even
closer than you have with your siblings
and your uncle certainly then you're
like an uncle or something like that so
i want to double double tap what you
just said because i think it is
incredibly important that the
relationship matters more than what you
are relating with say the science or the
thesis or the experiment so yeah please
go on yeah so anyway as far as like the
work of it man you know for me every
time i'm engaged in
something
you know i you know on the one hand i
just try to do the best that i can and
just be as careful as i can and if i
you know and then after there's a
certain point where it's just not under
your control right and you have to you
know
the face it's in the hands of the fates
have i been naughty or have i been nice
you know
and when it works you're like yes right
you know
and so um
you know it doesn't turn out uh a
hundred percent necessarily but at least
if you can get some scientist you know
it's so hard to be an experimentalist
man and you know it's it's you know i
but it's not as frustrating for me as
coding
especially when i'm working with other
people's code
but but you know and there is such a
sense of accomplishment
that you get but at a certain point you
know you start feeling like hey i'm the
redhead stepchild of astronomy i built
the hubble space telescope but the
people that get all the credit are the
ones that are using it you know to make
it are using it and
they get the you know they're the genius
but i made it
so i mean audience i did not make the
hubble space telecom had nothing to do
with it i'm just that was an example
exactly um putting their life on the
hands of
inherently fickle we a scientist release
to like control we think we have power
we think we have decisive intent on what
the future is going to bring you put
this thing on the rocket it can blow up
as you say one out of every two times
oh you wouldn't go down
this way you would not get on a
commercial airliner if it had this lower
rate of success right that's right yeah
absolutely right yeah yeah that is uh
you know it it is
not to you know no part of it is easy
and but you know what nothing in life is
easy right you know being broke ain't
easy
yeah
um yeah and i say that to say you know
we talk about the difficulty of it we
talk about the the chant you know what
the challenges of it
then you know there's a lot of
advantages to what i do you know the
change in my life that occurred because
i got a phd because i became educated
and you know for me you know i look at i
like to look at history a lot and when
you look at all these people in history
that were like oh you're keeping me from
an education and you know they so value
and they're still trying to get it and
now we're in a world where people like
school
school like cool you know educate what
nerd you know that kind of thought
process i don't wanna run anybody away
but like it's so hard right but you know
because reality is everything is hard no
matter what you do it's hard and you
know is it you know is it fulfilling is
another question right can you uh
you know then of course for some reason
there's your um
value to society and dignity is
sometimes associated with your your
career i don't like i don't think of it
that way but i realize that you know a
lot of society does so um
yeah it's hard but it's very worthwhile
yeah now talk about um you know some of
these
things that are universal we like to
think with scientists the public think
sciences we're all getting along we're
all trying to do the same thing you know
we're all in the name of science and
we're just pursuing truth
talk about what science is really like
you have a gripping passage and series
in the book yeah uh with your
competition against soho and and how
mister was in competition and how people
don't think about science as like
competitive but and yet they think of
scientists like children i'm like do you
know a kid who's not like competitive
possessive jealous you know anxious or
whatever so talk about like what is it
like to compete against something when
the competition's like what they call an
infinite game we're just you're never
going to win sign right like nobel prize
but you don't win science so talk about
competition what was that feeling like
again so first of all what was soho why
was the competition so fierce it must be
because the stakes were really high
right yeah the stakes are really high
you know when you uh make a new
observation you you have a edge up on
the competition if you have a new
instrument right the latest greatest
data is always going to give you new
stuff right that's why jwst has got you
know who knows what we're going to see
um
and so
there's a little sort of competition
that happens between rockets and
satellites so a rocket a sub-orbital
sounding rocket goes up and comes back
down quickly it's much less of a lead up
time and the cost is much less than a
satellite and what you can do with that
is you can prove technologies you can
advance them in their technical
readiness levels right so they can go on
satellites which can then take much more
pristine data for much longer periods of
time right so now imagine you have a
rocket flight and you have a bunch of
data and now here comes a satellite
that's coming online and you know their
data is coming and you haven't published
your data yet and so here's what i used
to say as a graduate student what i felt
like i observed uh i thought that there
were two types of experiments there were
experiments that are nearly impossible
to build right these are like my
condensed matter
friends but once you build them and get
them working the data is pretty
straightforward right you can analyze
data you're good to go you spend all
your time making a dang experiment then
note there are those experiments that
you know it's kind of straightforward to
make them but the data is darn near
impossible to analyze
that was us
okay
because our our detector was
photographic film which is not a linear
detector like our electronic detectors
and so extracting calibrating you know
we wanted to make um absolute flux
measurements uh apps you know and you
know measure how many photons
you know at what wavelength and you know
and so
you know we did we spent a lot of time
doing calibration exercises uh and so we
were doing so much time in the
experimental component we just and then
the analysis component was so tough
that you know it looked like we might
not be able to get stuff published
before someone else did which means that
we wouldn't be able to publish at all um
yep and you have to like keep keep your
eye on it and you also have to navigate
these waters of a competition for
funding it's like you know scarce
resources at every leg of the journey
so my phd advisor um
our mission was the first to get these
full disk images of the sun that you see
all the time with the plasma loops right
he was in competition with another
astronomer at an east coast university
i'm not going to say right yeah so
i become a young professor you know 15
years later or something and you know
after starting grad school and uh
i go to this conference and this
you know more mature colleagues say hey
i came are you interested in you know
doing this a particular experiment
together was a rocket flight experiment
i'm like yeah sure i was actually
thinking about doing that he's like
great i work with and he names mark's
you know number one for better
and i'm like wow
what are the chances those guys hate
each other now i'm gonna be working with
him right so we submit our proposal
it gets very
good ratings
but it's not funded
so i called people you know the rocket
community isn't that big right so i
called people who i thought would know
what the deal was and so this guy was
very straightforward with me he was like
hey look man you know we really don't
know you like that you know you're just
coming here from silicon valley uh and
you know we know what you've done
technologically
we don't want to give you the whole
rocket if you decide to to build the
just the instrument we probably would
have funded you but so next time around
here's what i suggest either partnering
or you know that sort of thing right so
the next year comes around and me in the
same collaboration we're about to strike
up again
and
my the guy who approached me originally
like oh yeah remember your um
your uh that other guy who was your you
know he's no longer with us he's doing a
different rocket with these other people
i'm like oh okay what are they gonna fly
guess what it was
my rocket your rocket yeah yeah and it's
gone and it went on to get um paper i
don't know if it was science or nature
or something like that yeah i called it
quiet q street quiet sun transverse
explorer telescope so dude that threw me
for such a loop
i was like i hate y'all i'm going to
another field
and i started i started working with um
the the the people that do uh galactic
archaeology uh joki visits andy becker
at washington josh bloom and peter
nugent at uh berkeley
because i was just like you know i don't
wanna forget y'all
you know this is you know i i ain't got
time for this i'm trying to you know
understand the universe here i don't
have
you know i gotta cult i gotta curate my
scientists right you gotta think no you
know which is a skill i think it's hard
to learn because in the beginning of
your career you got to say yes a lot
because because you don't have as many
opportunities and and in order to say
you know yes to the things that matter
sometimes you got to say no to other
things you also worked on a very
competitive field uh oh sorry go ahead
thank you is you know there was that
whole thing of like i i complained that
i had no shoes until i saw a man with no
feet right so i i told my colleagues
would have a couple of friends and a
couple of them were like well let me
tell you what happened to me and that
was way worse like
in both cases they actually got the won
the grant for the actual instrument but
somehow their colleagues had convinced
them that it was better to take the
grant even though it was their idea
their paid through their institution and
they took it
yeah kicked them off the prop yeah twice
two different people two different
countries right so
um you know the competition is fierce
and let me tell you one other thing
brian so i this is you know i like to
use humor a lot yeah and when i hear the
public discussion about science and
scientists and how opposite it is of how
we actually are yeah and let me tell you
what i mean
so you look at things that are
controversial because it um
runs a butt you know we start talking
about origins
our
faith traditions talk about the origin
of humans origin you know all this kind
of right so there's sort of like a
butting heads you know certain things
are the the topics that
i feel like the public thinks that the
world scientists get together in a room
every 30 40 50 years
and the topic is the same every time
what's the big lie we're all going to
agree on global warming evolution the
big bad you know
when the reality is we ain't agreeing on
nothing
right
there's no agreement
you know and it's not that we hate each
other is that we're all sheldon cooper
right
and and that's our job is to be
skeptical right i mean
science uh feynman said science is the
belief in the ignorance of experts not
the wisdom not the knowledge
if he had just thought oh well you know
schrodinger got it all right and
schrodinger thought oh newton got it all
right we'd never have schrodinger
einstein et cetera exactly man so i i i
agree completely and i i just want to
like kind of maybe brainstorm a little
bit i had on
one of your competitors last month a man
by the name of brian schmidt uh one of
the few brians that i know who have won
the nobel prize yeah and he
he was a he was a competitor of yours
when you were on the supernova cosmology
project
with with great disdain the competition
the toxicity of the competition between
those two groups and it's like no matter
where you go yeah what was that like to
be a part of that and and like was that
part of like when did you go to silicon
valley was that after s that was uh you
you were in uh implied materials and
then you went to and then you went to um
supernova cosmology project right you
made your millions of dollars from your
patents
millions billions and then you're like
i'll retire i'll be a a gentleman of
leisure now let me tell you what i did
right i had played my cards right all
the way up until i didn't
so you know these historic trends in the
market so man you know i negotiated my
way in the stock options and i was just
in there kicking butt you know seven
patents in a year and a half
and uh
so i you know i discovered i don't like
the culture
okay so i'm like you know nobody's
interested in the universe everybody's
talking about stocks and chips i wanna
you know let's
think big and they're like i mean i
can't tell you how many times you know
i'm engineering something i was like oh
yeah i think i understand the physics
and if we tell you and my major goal
nobody cares
all right nobody cares just get that
thing done and out right so anyway
um
we're talking about again
it's just like that silicon valley you
know kind of competition and
transferring the supernova cosmology
project it's kind of going back into the
so yeah that was such a toxic community
and i'll tell you one thing that
happened so when i became a young
professor you know i didn't take it for
granted that i could get funding in
uh anything that i had done so my first
year i submitted 10 proposals
and it was everything that i had done
right so i'm submitting some solar stuff
i'm submitting some detector stuff i'm
submitting right and i you know i was
getting these weird reviews right
excellent excellent fair
and so
you know i'm like oh yeah i'm gaining
insight right because one thing that
happened is one of my arts buddies at
nasa invited me to be on proposal
evaluation committee
very early
you know after i became a professor and
i'll tell you what was shocking to me
you know i'm a fan boy so when i was a
graduate student in the 90s and you know
everything wasn't digital yet
you might i don't know if you did this
but i would go get the journals
photocopy the papers and i just had all
these stacks of papers right yeah and so
what i would do is if i saw the same
person's name coming up
and you know in a field i'm like okay
i'm gonna go and get every paper that
person wrote right and read them
and i literally did that right yeah
anyway
i decide you know i attend this this
christmas party and there's a younger
astronomer at this party and i'm telling
him like oh yeah man here's how it goes
here's here's what you want to know
and when i told him about this
experience with one proposal that was
excellent excellent fair he goes oh
i i remember that
the person who reviewed it and i are
close and he told me about that uh yeah
and guess who it was
the competition of the previous group i
was in
yeah
right now
yeah
that's something i don't think most
people appreciate you know you get
reviewed by your competitors it's not
even likely to get reviewed by other
people and it goes for peer review it
goes for journal articles it goes
through grants and you know it leads to
some kind of ethical you know quandaries
and and by the way we never get like our
colleagues in medicine and law they take
classes on ethics we never get
scientific ethics class at least i never
did i don't remember any yeah or at
least like talks to the you know to the
tas on ethics and stuff like that yeah i
mean
like an hour you know every year and
like a online you know course that you
know is mind-numbingly boring but what
if we can see if you're moving your
mouse and all this stuff
but what if we
approach science the way we have
approached this that this uh pandemic
everyone who needs a vaccine will get a
vaccine yeah right
everyone who has a sound
meritorious scientific idea will get
that idea funded yeah that's not what
we're doing we are saying to ourselves
we are only going to fund this tiny
percentage of the feasible and
meritorious ideas right
what kind of approach how are we going
to compete with the klingons right and
like that right
yeah yeah and i think you know it's like
what are the solutions you know some of
my friends are like oh we should tax
emails you know because we invented
emails or semiconductors we're used to
work right i mean uh physicists invented
the semiconductor invented the laser
invented the transistor and you know
everything do we tax it do we have uh
you know i i think then you stifle
innovation but but i think it's it is an
important thing to think about how
scientists are just like
other people you know quote unquote
normal people absolutely but and i
wonder in your in your role as you know
part of your you know one of your 17
different jobs and hats that you wear is
communicator public you know
communicator and public face of science
i always feel like when i talk to my
colleagues i say you guys have a moral
obligation in my opinion to do
communication to the public because the
public pays your salary and better yet
it's it's for your own good because the
day that they give up on you and say
that you do not need are no longer
necessary because we don't have any wars
anymore panda you know whatever um it's
the end of the road for you and by the
way most of our colleagues true or false
hakeem would do what we do for free
right we're having fun we're playing
games so it's an existential risk for us
and yet my colleagues say oh i'm not
good at that i'm not good at speaking
and and you had a you know your journey
you know from the streets to the stars
it wasn't that you weren't taught this
growing up in the south you know like
how did you approach it do you approach
it as part of professional development
as an obligation as i call it a moral
obligation or what do you think
well i do feel obligated to be honest
with you but you know that comes from
even even when i was a child you know my
family was very engaged in the community
um and you know we're a rural community
so you know you know you have your
summer
uh well we sold beer and other products
uh
we uh you know you have your summer
softball and baseball games you know and
so like my brother-in-law was the
manager and so we would always you know
host the fish fries and you know all
this kind of thing but we were always
community and church involved right as a
you know as a young guy so i brought
that in and then when i went to tougaloo
college you know historically black
colleges they all they they also and and
also i went to the military first right
so also you have that sense of service
and then you know when i went there to
historically black colleges and and i
joined cap alpha psi fraternity
um
you know our fraternities aren't about
you know these historically black
fraternities they're not about let's
party right they're about achieve right
you know uh community service that's
that's what they're about so this whole
like
built-in so when i show up in graduate
school
if you're an american african-american
graduate student
you know there is a huge percentage of
the population you know you you've now
in physics or chemistry something
mathematics you know you you're you're
rare
right in this country okay so
you uh
are requested by people that are serving
communities that are similar to what
you're doing because you know they want
to see their students their kids advance
to where you have advanced so then you
start going out right now for me
you read you saw my book you know i gave
at least one sermon
you know but you know for me i was a kid
in the country
and you know
you had like one channel that worked
reliably you know it was a turn go
outside when it got to the point where
you go outside and turn the antenna then
we were big time you know
you know before you had the aluminum
foil on the thing so what do you do you
sit around telling stories all the time
so one thing that i had in my book that
i cut out and i fear that eddie murphy
has scooped me is you know i i memorized
rudy ray moore's um
albums so there was uh shine and
dolomite completely memorized at like 10
years old right and then later when i'm
13 i memorized a signifying monkey so
google these things and look them up
but all of this ability to tell a story
and then you know i had to go to church
every sunday your parents get in there
right and so what do they do you got to
give a speech when you're a kid easter
give a speech right so you go in there
and you get accustomed to just standing
in front of others making people laugh
you know that sort of thing right and so
um
it came very natural
it was a discovery it wasn't a desire it
was a discovery the first thing that
happened is that as when i became the
president of my fraternity at tougaloo
you know you got to do the service stuff
so one of the people that i teamed up
with was national junior achievement and
so we went into classrooms and taught
these kids economics and so you know
they give you a curriculum
but they don't really give you
here's how you interact and dude i'm a
total ham give me a room full of kids oh
we're about to have a ball right so you
know the teachers are like oh my god
you're amazing and the reason why it's
just like us right so brian
i'm gonna give you a little bit of
insight all right i had a little bit of
acting training yeah
i see some of our colleagues they get a
shot to go on a tv show and you can see
clearly that they're talking to our
colleagues they're not talking to the
audience that's regular folks they're
like my colleagues are looking over my
shoulder i better be incredibly you know
and and so uh
if you know and here's the other thing i
want to say
i don't think it's i think your
colleague is right i don't think it is
for everybody yeah right and and here's
what i you know we you know everybody is
everything isn't for me you know what i
mean like sure i might be the greatest
basketball player who's ever lived the
prettiest guy in the history of humanity
the smartest the highest jumping fastest
running quick anyway yeah i might be
great a lot of things but i'm a complete
idiot at a lot of things right
so
recognizing you know where you have a
gap where you have a lack and you know
that's part of being a good scientist i
think you know and
yeah
yeah
everything
my thesis advises you to say that's why
they call it research not reading you
know it's like if you knew all the
answers it wouldn't be uh it wouldn't be
yeah well let's talk about research
let's talk about your mentor
walker who was the mentor and the is
this advisor of sally ride who's my
colleague here at uc san diego first
american woman in space uh inspiration
to women and men around the world um
what was he like as a person you
described very candidly you know he was
kind of like a father figure you have
two father fathers in your in your story
and we'll talk about both of them but
although i had three really but three oh
yeah okay
the other was my brother-in-law but you
know how it is when you write a book
absolutely 150 000 words they're like
50 000 words gotta go you know what easy
way to do that hakeem get rid of
characters
it's called control x yeah exactly yeah
um so talk about art what was he like
as a person a man overcame many barriers
he broke through a lot of ceilings but
he was also you know a top one of the
best scientists
um you know of that generation and sadly
he's no longer with us but uh but talk
about what what what he meant to you and
the importance of of mentorship and
almost as academia has to have a father
it has to be platonic but but we are
kind of like advisors where are sort of
like paternal or maternal right yeah
i'll turn i'll i will say something to
you that um
you know when i was at nasa headquarters
i went and had a conversation with dr
freeman robowski who's the president of
the university of maryland baltimore
county okay
and there's certain things that are
outstanding about this guy one is you
remember when martin luther king was
leading a group of people over the
bridge in selma alabama i don't remember
personally but yes right exactly well
freeman wrobowski was a kid on that
bridge yeah he was beaten
there's footage of it right
so the other thing that's notable about
him is that if you look at the top
producers of african americans and you
know technical fields it's always
dominated by historically black colleges
and universities and like the top 15.
with the exception of one university and
that is the university here's the
university right so um
i asked him you know about what you know
what he finds effective and so for me a
lot of the things that i do that are
effective
i do them because you know it's not like
i read anything right it's just kind of
luck like you know it's hard because i
have a uh i go to a
an interview or something that someone
is like job interview yeah so tell us
how you blow up i'm like look
i can't tell you how i don't know it
just does you know when i when i you
know when i leave people they just are
highly motivated and they get their
stuff done they succeed i have no idea
what i'm doing that's different than
anyone else right i'm just taking care
of every day as it happens right me and
me you know so art was one of the three
first the first three research
african-americans in astronomy and
astrophysics now that's different from
the first guy first person to obtain a
phd in astronomy the first person to
obtain a phd in astronomy
was harvey banks
in the 60s and he
uh became a professor at howard and
didn't really have much of a research
career but it was an educator right
but before him in 1956 karl rouse got a
phd at caltech
now his his phd work was not in
astronomy and astrophysics
he was doing i think something to have
to do with particle physics you know in
that era right so uh karl rouse
uses a super computer to solve the saha
equation at this for the core of the sun
right so you calculate the state of
ionization uh inside the core of the sun
and you know he got nature papers out of
this okay so in a way he was the first
uh astrophysicist
that had a research career in
astrophysics then in 62 i think george
carruthers and art walker got their phds
so george carruthers goes on to be the
first person to put an observatory on
another body that's not the earth right
he put it he put a ultraviolet
instrument on the moon that looked back
at the earth and discovered the daytime
uv glow
and a few other things i don't recall
off the top of my head
and then you had art right so
they go way back okay
now um
art as a person you know he was a short
of stature
but he was very dignified and formal in
his bearing you know i often compare him
to someone like colin powell for example
but the thing about him because of his
bearing and the force of his personality
even though he was short of stature you
know you felt like he was seven foot six
you know you felt like you were standing
in front of shaquille o'neal and it was
the same way and he was and the thing
about him is how patient and calm he was
and i picked that up from him because
you see my natural
being is buckwild right so um
you know art people would ask art
questions that were utterly ridiculous
and art would treat each person with
dignity and patience and answer their
question so i'm like ah
i see that
right i see that
um
and
but art
was also
really tough
okay and so when i started it was at a
tough time for him because him and his
father had a schism at a certain point i
don't remember the details of what it
was about but his father got nearer to
the end of his life and art brought his
father into his home and because you
know i have i don't know what it is
about me but you know people open up to
me personally you know i always i used
to say i got this oprah thing or
something i don't know what it is you
know um but you know i'm a good person
to tell your secrets too because i
forget them immediately but anyway
um
he would talk to me about his family
right and he talked to me about
uh
getting close to his father after having
a schism he would talk to me about my
relationship with my parents right and
how important it is and then when his
father really started um
to decline was at the same time where we
were behind on launching this rocket so
he was under major stress and then
stupid things started happening in the
lab
i'm not going to go into the details it
wasn't me
but there was say
destruction of incredibly expensive and
hart would say
you know
you could pay for a year of your
phd
for breaking that if you know what i'm
saying
yeah but the other thing about him was
he was so about rigor man he just
hammered it hammered it and and so one
of the things that i became to advocate
for is he never framed it in this way
here's what he would say to me
he would say i can
did you blah blah blah blah and i'd say
yeah it happened and he was like really
do you know that it happened and i'm
like yeah i told such and such and you
know they did it it's like okay do you
know that it happened i'm like yeah i
saw him walk out the room right after i
told him like do you
know
that it happened i'm like i'll be right
back right and i learned what i felt was
perhaps one of the most important things
i ever learned the difference between
knowing and not knowing what does it
mean to actually know something right
and so you've verified it you've
confirmed it it's not belief i've
accepted it as true and not and i'm not
verified to be true right when i know it
versus believing it and then sometimes
you know there is
you know processes that you can trust to
some degree sometimes like the
scientific process so you know i don't
have to go and redo
you know i'm going to build my own cern
and you know
you know
you know what i'm saying so uh
so art was really about
making sure like i'll give you an
example mr let's take mister for example
so when art
flew the very first rocket that got the
full disc images of the sun like we get
every day now his colleague said two
things
number one there's an optical problem
with your telescope
because you see how there's that
emission that covers you see how the
plasma loops that you see on the limb of
the sun they have constant cross-section
but we know that magnetic fields diverge
with altitude
right it's sort of like
albert einstein with the cosmological
constant right like i know
what i don't actually know right so i'm
going to do this right and the other
thing they say it is you see how there's
emission all over the disk
that means that your telescope pass
bands right you only left through this
narrow wave of the night are not
properly tuned something's wrong there
so here's what art decided to do that
first flight had three telescopes
after that the flights had 16 to 22
telescopes so i'm going to use multiple
telescopes that do the exact same thing
tuned to the exact same wavelength but
they're different optical configurations
single reflection hershelians double
reflection ritchie creations double
reflection castle grains so if it's
identical you know the loops have comes
across it's not my telescope's is what
nature is doing ah okay so it's right
filling in the fail face
systematic error checks yeah exactly
right so you know you have all this
redundancy in but it wasn't because that
was the best way to do the experiment
that's the way to convince the
colleagues that we're doing it the right
way and then there's the whole issue of
you know
sort of spectroscopy
you know is what you're doing with these
mirrors uh and so now if you're able to
make spectroscopic observations you're
able to make
physical measurements from the light
right that's what i always you know that
was my other big you know i you know
reveal in in grad school was
where does light come from you know you
know like you know it's like what is
matter made of adams everybody tells you
that right but then you say where does
light come from uh and the answer is you
know i tell this to my students
if you're nowhere near a neutron star or
a black hole
matter makes it that's right
and the identity of what the matter is
is encoded in the light and what the
matter is doing isn't coding the light
so interpreting this light is how we do
this science but it has to be done in a
rigorous way and you got to prove it to
your colleagues so we then had to
develop that science but art had already
done that for x-rays because remember
that whole battle between the rocket and
the uh satellite yeah in his early work
he had the first x-ray satellite to
study the sun
spectroscopic one right
and we got the grant first but a rocket
beat him
so he likes to say
i didn't get the first x-ray spectra of
the sun
i got the you know fifth through three
thousand you know the best yeah yeah the
best right
yeah and they laid the foundation for
you know how x-ray uh analysis of
astrophysical plasmas would unfold in in
the future right um and that's the sort
of thing that i employed so art was but
art was also super giving you know he
always was a member of community groups
and he was super giving to me right he
would take me like like you know i when
i first joined one of our you know one
of the grad student i was perhaps
closest with uh kind of took me under
his wing
in a real big brother kind of way you
know how a big brother will help you but
also punch you in the face yeah yeah
craig
he wouldn't punch me he he kicked me one
time kicked me in the butt and i looked
at him like craig
if you ever so one thing about science
communication you asked observing art
teaching his astronomy class because he
made the graduate students run the slide
projector
yeah taught me how to communicate
science so if you look at like
especially if you look at my first ted
talk i basically embodied art whenever i
gave my talks right but craig deforest
was another guy
who was a great science communicator so
he became after he left stanford the the
science communicator for the solar
physics division of the um double a s
you know and until very recently right
he was it for like 25 years or something
like that so i had these two great
science communicators to give me you
know as a as a example
of being a science communicator right
yes
yeah and that's part of you know the
public persona of science and the
appreciation of science i mean my only
quip is is you know when people say oh
no that's too hard for me like and i
always say oh yeah i know yeah quantum
field theory is so easy you learn that
you know coming out of the womb and no
no i had a study there oh oh so you
study things that you perceive have
value uh but so it must be that if you
don't study and work on your
communication skills
maybe you don't perceive it as having
value and maybe it's denigrated a little
bit anyway i i do feel like we we you
know every every scientist should at
least pay attention to it because it's
the soft skills that really lead to our
career i mean you could be you know the
greatest you know brain have the
greatest memory the greatest processing
power i don't care wikipedia is going to
beat you you know wikipedia is a lot
smarter than you yeah and it knows more
facts than you but it doesn't have
wisdom and it can't relate to people
and um you know for those reasons i do
feel like it's a neglected skill i do
try to accentuate that with my students
and and really inculcated them a desire
uh to do that and there's the old jerry
seinfeld joke that you know people are
more scared of public speaking than they
are of dying so you'd rather be at the
inside the casket than giving the eulogy
at the funeral um
but i want to turn you know the other
thing man this is what i see it seems
like every young person is a science
communicator now right every graduate
student has their twitter vid i mean
they're slick with it yeah yeah
because i think also that people see it
um in various ways right it's not just
as like okay this is a public good yeah
you know it also can be
um it's a way to make money or you know
it's a way for me to get my creative
person out right or you know it's many
or i like to teach i like to engage with
you know people in prisons or people in
the community or kids you know and so
there's so many different avenues and so
many different styles and you know i
think that
um you know study after study has shown
that reaching people is very granular
you know the more like you are a person
that's trying to accomplish something
and you're their
guide to it the more receptive um they
are to it you know and so one study i
saw recently was a study on who gets
patents
and basically they found that oh the the
kids who go on to get patents or the
kids
or the people who were exposed to patent
getters yeah right but then they looked
at it more you know finer and they saw
that oh
if it was a young lady and she was
exposed to a woman
who had patents that was even way more
effective you know it's quantitative
it's not
you know uh
you know it's like a social study done
with data that scientists would say okay
this is real you know because you know
how we are um i want to ask you uh a
difficult question because i do see you
as as you know in some ways like a
parent's dream you know you know with
the stuff that you curiosity that you
had seriously the inquisitiveness the
forthrightness the boldness look you
change your name you have courage man
and you did it um you did it you're
you're self-made in a way and you're
also
father raised and father not raised but
i want to ask you you know like one of
the greatest things i'm teaching my kids
right now that that drugs are basically
the the one thing i won't forgive
because when you when as i understand it
it depends that different drugs have
different effects right but i do see
gateway drugs and i see other things and
i've never done a drug in my life maybe
i should have but
i'm a nerd too
i don't have as many brain cells as you
to rub around like i can't afford to
lose the three i have left
man me and stephen hawking we were
like that's the only rubik's cube i can
solve you know i'm a lord that's smart
man
my 16 year old son came back from
christmas holiday oh my god it's all
rumors cube now messing up oh i'm like
oh i do he's always you know i've always
you know my mom when he was like four i
think he's smarter than you i'm like
what
i've been fighting this
so you know i want to think i want to
ask you if it's if it's fair if it's not
you don't have to answer it but but like
yeah i look at i look at your upbringing
i look at what and just for people you
know you talk about this kindly in the
book you were you you had uh experience
with drugs you actually were dealing
drugs at stanford of all places you're
cooking crack you talk about that um how
can
how can first of all let's talk about
that you know the trope black man
single parent you know mostly his father
left him although i'm a white man my
father left me but that's another thing
it wasn't like that nobody left you know
they broke up yeah there's there's no
monopoly right uh but um you know
there's this trope right in the cycle of
poverty the cycle of weakness talk about
that was that something like that people
get wrong about you or that it's just a
trope oh he came from the ghetto he came
from or wherever he came from the deep
south no no his dad was a drug deal is
that a trope or is there something to
learn from it are you sick
you know it's really interesting that
you bring that up because i just was
listening to something or watching
something about exactly that and how it
came about from this document this
analysis that was done and you know if
you look at these stat you know the
statistics and they looked at it as like
you know crisis in the black family well
guess what it's no longer just a black
family so the statistic that everybody
likes to you know point out is like 70
of black kids are born to black mothers
who are unmarried but guess what
white women who uh
would only you know without much
education
68 of their kids no born out of wedlock
right
and the other thing is there was a study
done of parental involvement so even
though you're not married your parents
are still involved in your life and so
it turned out that african-american men
had the highest parental involvement of
all races
right so even though my parents were
married when i was born and divorced
my father you know now it wasn't like
you know so the guy i wrote my book with
another jewish guy whose father was a
neuroscientist um you know there were
these times where he was like well you
know when they gave you an iq test and
they discovered then your parents you
know you know how like they'll send you
to being a gymnastics camper i'm like no
dude ain't nobody gonna do that where
i'm from you know they're like you know
nobody gives a care um but my story is
extreme right most kids weren't me i was
you know
there was
every guy in the eighth grade wasn't
selling joints
it was just me right every guy in ninth
grade wasn't selling joints it was just
me and then you go to stanford and get a
phd from stanford well yeah but no a lot
of the people at stanford were selling
joints right the difference is that you
know like i told you before i'll tell my
story is some high-ranking person in the
world who's now in black oh let me tell
you my story and the difference is is
that it becomes a part of your identity
if you're part of that lore economic uh
identity group right but if you're in a
higher oh it doesn't really matter
right like you know
at least one president i'm not gonna
name because i told you you know the
hater listener is gonna be like yeah
yeah in his book i snorted a few lines i
spoke right right man i tell you this
you know just like i say science ain't
science drugs ain't drugs right and what
i mean by that is you know precision and
prediction in physics is very different
than in say medicine
right so you can't say science right and
it's the same thing with drugs you know
having a beer
smoking a cigarette drinking some coffee
cocaine heroin you know all this array
of things there are some of them of
course
don't ever go anywhere near that but the
biggest problem that parents have
is when you take that extreme position
and they leave home and they see their
colleagues you know i'm saying i'm not
touching that drug while y'all are
drinking and doing lines and smoking i'm
gonna be there and if they gonna have
the exact same life you're like huh what
the hell was dad talking about they
didn't die instantly right most people
don't become alcoholics who drink
alcohol most people don't become drug
addicts right that's right they become
successful
professionals
you know um and so
having these tropes
it lives in everybody's mind so not only
will people look at you in a certain way
people look at themselves and i guess
now i'm disqualified i can't do it you
know so one of the questions i've gotten
over and over is like man how could you
have been doing that while being at
stanford i'm like clearly statistically
i wasn't the only one yeah
right like several people are doing it
chances are your parents do you know and
you know parents and teachers are big
hypocrites right you know i was talking
to a
a good example of that is there was this
one guy i knew
and uh
you know this guy he was married but he
you know he loved to talk about his
exploits of the past right
even though he was a devoted husband you
know hardcore christian guy you'll be
loved yeah man you know to impress right
he thought it was impressive
but they had a daughter who was coming
of age and their daughter had promised
that she would not you know have
relations with a boy after graduating
high school
and after this couple graduated high
school that same day they had relations
right
and so
he was telling me about this and how he
went through
right and i'm like dude you're talking
to the wrong guy
you did it i did it your wife did it
your mama did you know i'm saying and
the world didn't fall apart right right
so stop being you know it's not a
tragedy you know there's responsibility
that has to be taken there's care you
want to get you know you know want to do
things right way and things like that
history right right yeah but don't treat
things in a way that's gonna make you
lose your credibility with your child
right for being you know
a hypocrite or you know so i i try to
tell my kids the truth like for example
what i've come to understand about our
educational system
right yeah you're not learning mastery
there most of the time especially when
it comes something like mathematics
i now firmly feel like i have enough
evidence to say that if you learn
mathematics well
right
before you graduate high school it
happens for one of two reasons it's in
your house slash community or you're
lucky
yeah right i wasn't either one
right
i had to learn it later
you know
um and uh
so now i have a son yeah and my son
completes algebra one at seven algebra
two intrigue at nine starts calculus at
ten so i was teaching them
okay teaching them how to master and
then i see with schools and i'm like
look dude let's be let's be frank about
this school ain't where you're getting
mastery from
in fact what they're doing
is bs bogus solution right it's not you
know
i got that from my math teacher in the
navy uh mr galloway he's saying that
he was so good at knowing how you're
going to think incorrectly and lead you
right down this incorrect path
like dude that's right yeah yeah and
after that he writes bs on the board
right now we were in the military you
know we got to be proper he writes we're
like oh
shocked and he goes
bogus solution
but yeah man it really is uh doing an
education now i think that um you know
there needs to be a major revision in
how we do things and clearly to educate
the kids you got to educate the parents
you know my goal is to turn every parent
into me
uh and so
my you know my mom claimed oh maybe he's
smarter than you
i said no to hell he ain't his daddy got
a phd in physics both exactly right they
need to graduate high school it matters
there's a reason why people want to send
their kids to the best school and yeah
it actually does matter it's not the kid
it's the training of the brain and the
mind so let me give you an example so
he's doing ap physics now
and
in high school he showed me his uh
book right and it's a real college you
know like you know what are you
university physics that type of book
right yeah and i'm like man this is
great
but you guys should have done this by
like week two or three he's like no dad
you don't understand man it's really
hard for everybody and i don't
understand why you know i try to teach
my friends sometimes they just don't get
it i know it's because you taught me how
to think a certain way but i don't
understand how they miss it you know
um and that's a key thing knowing how to
think
being trained to think for yourself
right to be logical and um critical
thinking
we don't teach that right and so when i
became a part of the federal education
ecosystem
i'm like yeah i'm gonna push to get
critical thinking talk
and guess what i surprise surprise i
wasn't the first person in history to
think of this
but
[Music]
it got killed why
because it undermined parents and faith
so if you teach your kid so that same
guy for example i told you about who was
hypocritical with his daughter i
remember one time you know so you ask a
physicist dad why is the sky blue right
you got an actual answer right right so
i taught this you know and i didn't
teach him enough tax so maybe like five
or six and him and his little cousins
run to that guy and ask him some
question like that why is guy blue and
he gives an answer whatever it is what
is lightning you know something like
that and he gives the answer you know
the kid's like okay and my son goes
that's not an answer to that question
i'm like dude
i have respect but but yeah right you're
mine yeah exactly
respect
its job man people think of uh you know
it's hard to get a phd it's hard it's
hard to be a professor get out you know
through all the academic hunger games
how to be a taxi driver it's hard to be
a bus driver it's hard to work at a i've
done them all
that's right yeah so and then kind of
wrap up that i want to uh convey you
know just i think of you as this you
know kind of you know my notes as i'm
jotting down as i'm listening to your
voice and the mellifluous tones that you
elicit uh i know where you're going i
know where you're going
world's greatest basketball player in
history and and speaker and the singer
of baritone lyrics um i would listen i
sing in one note that's out of tune so
i play one instrument it's spotify
i want to ask you you know like i've
often heard it said you know like oh i
wouldn't change anything about my past
because you know it's my past worldwide
the paths the quantum paths you know and
path integral that's what got me to
where i am and i'm happy with where i am
you know i always tell people like what
if you search on google you search this
term how can you search um it was the
best thing that ever happened to me yeah
you're saying what was the sentence the
person said right before that it's i got
fired she broke up with me it's always
something bad it's never something good
so i want to ask you in that same vein
like in your in your and i usually ask
this in the context of my final
questions but we covered so much i i
feel like i would be redundant to go
over it again but
in your pet would you change anything is
there stuff that you would change you
know uh how would you because you you
talk a lot about the heartbreak of
dealing with your father and
and then losing art as you say yeah very
touching and and and dealing with i mean
straight up racism and it's true and you
don't use that as a you know you're not
like harping on that as you admit
candidly you're your foibles and so
forth is there a ch
an element a path integral is there a
part you know one of the vertices of the
feynman diagram that made hakeem who he
is would you change it would you do
anything different would you go back in
your 20 year old self would you would
you tell him
i'm too scared to do something like that
man because i'm like you know it's the
butterfly effect right you know things
have turned out i've survived and you
know people around me like man
especially 2020 you know losing close
friends like just a month ago one of my
closest friends was in the book you know
i talked about my you know not as much
as i did when it's 150 000 words my band
crew
my drum line story man there's three of
us left
wow
yeah and you know i'm sorry early last
year about a year ago our heart and soul
andrew mcgee the guy who went to the
state science fair with me oh yeah yeah
he had a heart attack and passed away
and then the guy who you know told me
all about dating like boy i say it like
you mean it
you know jackie pugh and jack if you
would say this too i'm gonna curse but
you know i go home you know i you know
come back from uh tougaloo and i've like
studied or whatever and i've discovered
that oh those bright ones are the
planets that's jupiter right and so you
know we're standing outside in the
middle of night in mississippi you know
it's all blue and we're doing whatever
we're doing but you're always talking
yeah and i would always start like oh by
the way did you guys know and my man
jackie pugh who just passed he would
always go yeah he go with that [ __ ]
again
love them man i love them yeah i'm sorry
yeah man yeah so
that's amazing well actually i want to
ask you one of my final questions is
always involves a movie uh 2001 a space
odyssey when these you know primates in
africa they come upon this monolith you
know this is a solid black thing and
then we don't know what it is it could
be a time capsule it could be a warning
or whatever but i want to ask you if you
had a monolith you know that was
guaranteed at time caps to last a
billion years
what would you put on it what would you
put in it
[Laughter]
it's leaving now so yeah that means
you're you're ready to go right back
i'll tell you something brian so i was
talking to rocky cobb you know rocky
cobb yeah of course chicago yeah and so
this is when i first met him back in
2003.
and he told me two things that stuck
with me he was like oh you know you're
only 30. you only the third astro person
i know from uh
new orleans louisiana whether it's me
and there's some other giant of
astronomy and there's you i'm like well
thanks rocky
you know i just graduated from like oh
no
right and then he says uh he gives that
apocryphal quote from mark twain and he
applies it to physics and you know he
talks about albert einstein he was like
it's not what we don't know is what we
know that ain't so that's right right so
i started thinking about that in terms
of the universe and our reality
uh and so you know one of the things
like you know space and time like just
right where i started right yeah and i i
figured i had this thought
i'm like okay you know me and brian
are experiencing this moment and we call
it now and we believe
don't know it we believe that there was
this thing called the past and the
universe is evolved up to this point
and now is the actual real now
and beyond now there's that thing called
the future
that's right that was like but every
person who ever lived would have that
exact same thought every conscious
entity that's aware of time so what
makes my now the actual now and not
there now
so it seems like the existence of
consciousness makes all world lines
co-equal in a way so as far as i know
it's 100 million years from now and i'm
already dead
that's right so if you want to
understand why hakeem is so unfiltered
you know after you die they tell all
your secrets
you've done so much for so many may you
continue uh to inspire to create to
innovate
and uh and to spread these wonderful
ideas and knowledge that you have so
infectious the best kind of virus is the
mind virus
and i hope we get to meet again it's so
much fun to meet you in washington dc
yeah go ahead i got to say one more
thing brian yeah you know just looking
at you man i was like wow that guy is a
super nerd
surely he's a hater
but then after his car we have all the
same friends and then i get to meet you
now i'm like this dude this is cool he's
a cool nerd he's not a hater that's
right yeah oh if you want a rebuttal
i'll i'll let you introduce to you to my
mother-in-law she will she will rebut
that and oh no i think that i really
appreciate it thanks for spending your
time
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
do
[Music]
you